hey everybody so let's get this started
my name is Kent C Dodds and I'm going to
be talking about react with you all and
this evening and/or whenever whatever
time of day it is wherever you are so
let's just jump into things I've got a
couple of slides here and we'll go over
some logistics and stuff for the next
hour that will be together so yeah so
this is some stuff about me we're gonna
be learning react and yeah just a bunch
of little icons and things you can click
on I've got my slides right here maybe
we'll add those to the to the notes at
sites comm slash Kent C Dodds slash
learn - react so these are my slides
from my normal workshop then which is
like a full-day workshop and very very
interactive and so yeah just be aware
that some of the like exercises and
things are kind of catered toward a
hands-on react react workshop this will
not really be hands-on like you can
follow along if you want to but we only
have an hour tonight so we won't be
doing everything for example we won't be
doing the air squats that I normally
like to do but though you can feel free
to do air squats health is good thing so
like I said it the the exercises and
things you can actually do on your own
you'll see there are lots of comments
and the exercises to tell you exactly
what to do this is really fundamental
stuff and so whether you've been using
react for a long time or you're just
wanting to get into it this will be
really valuable because often when we
start building products with a framework
or something we don't really understand
what exactly is going on under the hood
or how things are working and so that's
hopefully what I'll be able to give you
from this it's a very very bare-bones so
we're not like I start out with just
index.html file so that you can draw a
clean separation between react the
framework and all the other stuff like
web pack and things so yeah we're all
the examples aren't 100% practical it's
not we're not covering everything you
can do with react but most things the
next thing about react is that it's
pretty
has a pretty small API surface area and
I'm not going to go through every single
API and say like okay so let's look at
the docs here all the api's lifecycle
methods and things it's it is a little
bit more practical than that but yeah
it's not everything so we are going to
be talking about react create elements
and JSX
and how those relate to like really all
that far I'm not going to give you any
time to do the exercises on your own and
so yeah that's unfortunate but that's
kind of the nature of the time limit
that we have so we'll probably get
through quite a bit more than we would
if you were doing the exercises on your
own and give you time for that and the
cool thing about having this recorded is
that you can watch it later and pause it
and do the exercises and then watch my
solution okay cool so if you haven't set
it up this is how you do it there you
can actually run everything in code
sandbox so if you haven't heard of code
sandbox before it you're gonna have your
mind blown because it's amazing so this
is the repository for it we have a git
er chat but I'm not going to open that
up I'm gonna use the YouTube chat maybe
there's a lot of chatter which is great
um but I'll try to keep up on questions
and stuff in there but yeah if you go to
the repo and then go to code sandbox IO
go on that link there then it'll open up
in code sandbox which is a full like
it's almost like an integrated developer
experience an IDE in the browser it even
runs the tests which is like really
awesome
so yeah this you can do most of the
workshop just right in here so you don't
have to install anything which I think
it's pretty bad so yeah you can find a
link to this repo in the description of
the video ok so once you get that set up
just a couple logistics we're not in
person so there's no real raising hands
I will try to keep an eye on the chat
here but
um it's kind of hard so yeah if you have
something just go like in the chat or
something and feel free to answer each
other's questions I think that is really
helpful yeah and when you're going
through the exercises fill out the
elaboration and feedback forms for the
exercises that'll help you solidify what
you're learning in your brain which is
useful if you have questions for me that
are not related to this feel free to ask
on my AMA or firstsearch because I've
got like 400 questions that I've
answered on there and then as always
follow me on twitter because i tweet
things and some people think it's used
um so the normal routine for my
workshops is I intro to the use case
that we're trying to support and then we
do an exercise and then elaboration and
you fill out the elaboration or feedback
form and then if you have some extra
time you you do these extra things help
each other and stuff or I'm just gonna
skip all this stuff and we'll go I'll
finish the exercise for you okay so
that's it that's like literally all my
slides no more slides slides are boring
okay so here we go I've got the project
set up locally and yeah we're gonna
actually start in this intro directory
so here we have exercises exercises
final this is actually a create react
app app so if you've used create react
app before then this should be pretty
familiar you can look in the
package.json and check out the scripts
that we have here we'll be using some of
those and but from the write get-go we
just have these exercises and then the
final version of the exercise so if you
want a peek at the final version then
you can do that so sorry I just realized
I don't have things arranged the way
that I wanted them to be arranged move
things over a little bit
um people are saying nice things in the
chat Thank You that makes me feel good
okay so let's go ahead and I've already
opened up this file and you can just in
your terminal open intro exercises zero
zero dot HTML that'll pop it open in
your browser so I'm gonna pop that open
and look oh my goodness
where's the code we're gonna actually
start with a very very basic hello world
in just JavaScript so we're not even
gonna do react for this first thing so
to get us started we're gonna have a
buddy
and then we're gonna have a div and
we're gonna give that div an ID of root
and then we're gonna have a script and
that script is gonna be type
text/javascript love java scripts and
yeah for this javascript we're going to
have a variable I'm gonna get the root
element or we'll just call it root l and
that will be a document that element by
ID root all right sweet so now I'm going
to make our element document create
element do it's the kind of element we
want to create I'm going to set the text
content to low world and then just for
fun I'm going to set the class name
ooh container you know because why not
and then we'll say root L appendchild
element
okay so this is how we do this in
JavaScript i refresh and i get that here
let's pull up in the developer tools
pulling bottom make sure we don't get
any errors in the console alright cool
so that's hello world in a regular
JavaScript we're document create element
to make an element and then when you pin
that to our root you think of that as
kind of rendering this element to the
our root element if I don't do that
you're not going to see anything in here
this element is just like existing
somewhere in in memory it's not actually
being rendered to the user so yeah so
let's go ahead I'm seeing some questions
so let me address some of those really
quick
quick question can you include Redux in
this tutorial I actually will not be
including redox and that's totally
intentional I have a talk actually I
have a blog post let me log
donc on how to react there we go
and I'm sorry I can't actually paste
links in the chat I think unless maybe a
moderator can yeah I can't paste links
in the chat so you have to google it but
yeah how to react and I talked about how
it's a really bad idea to start with
read X so we're not going to be doing
that today because that would be more
distracting than helpful
so it's II will this live stream be
updated later
probably maybe I don't know I can't tell
the future but this content like lots of
this content is like it's all totally up
to date today and most of this content
actually hasn't changed for many
versions of reacts these fundamentals
are are true for lots of versions of
react um let's see oh that's really nice
Benny what type of program use for these
type of recordings check out my AMA k CD
- I am Amy that's are actually just a
github repo and I answered that question
there you can search around ok so let's
take a look at the next one
and feel free to like ping me in here oh
good question from somebody named
machine are you a robot okay is react
like angular or like bootstrap it's more
like angular bootstrap is a bunch of CSS
and some JavaScript for interactivity
it's like a UI library for like design
system react is more building user
interfaces so you could actually build
something like bootstrap with react and
people have so yeah it's definitely more
like angular in that way in the way that
its framework but you'll see it's quite
different in actual implementation which
editor using using AC yeah I am PS code
that will take you to my editor settings
and lots of information about that
on that note my font theme so you'll go
to that and that will send you to a
tweet that I just tweeted today so that
people don't ask me about my font and my
theme because everybody asked about my
font to my team so learn more about that
there am I going to do any context API
stuff in this tutorial no I'm not but if
you go to Cassini - I am slash advanced
react that will take you to a course
where I I do go into context I also have
blog posts about context and also on my
youtube channel
UNITA I am YouTube you'll find the I
have somewhere on there like look at my
playlist my talks and workshops I have a
recorded version
the advanced react component patterns
course which I gave it at PayPal to some
co-workers so you can learn more about
the context API there okay cool wait now
we can move on feel free to interrupt me
with questions that you have that are
both relevant and not relevant but
hopefully mostly relevant okay so the
next thing that we're going to do I have
our script here this is basically the
same thing that we had before just with
more comments let me navigate to this
thing okay so we have our rendered hello
world so now I'm going to bring in react
and we're just using script tags so I've
actually got react Dom and react in here
and react is responsible for an API
called react dot create element so this
is how we crew to document create
elements you have a react create element
and we'll take a look at that then react
Dom is responsible for the same thing we
have here with this appendchild
you can take react elements that you got
from react and react Dom will render
that element to the dumb you also have
react native and you have the ability to
render to a string of HTML rather than a
Dom node so you can do server-side
rendering and there's a whole bunch of
other renderers there's even a renderer
for react to render react elements to
word document or to a PDF or to canvas
so there's that separation between
creating react elements and rendering
those react elements to some sort of
environment so let's go ahead and re
implement this using using react so I'm
gonna say react dot create element and
then react create elements or react out
create element that API is a little bit
different from document dot create
element I guess I figured you don't want
a monkey patch a bunch of properties on
two on two things and so instead you can
set those right away as an
object so here instead of text content
of hello world we're actually going to
call this children and it kind of makes
sense if I were to make a div and I'd
say hello world this is text content but
it's also a child of the div and so I
can apply that same children concept to
a span or whatever else that I want and
so just calling it children not worrying
about the text content idea I kind of
like that so that's what the children
are going to be so we got text content
and then class name we actually have the
same thing container
whoops I just did something okay
there we go
okay
oh so now we have an element but this is
not a Dom element let's actually take a
look really quick at right here and bump
the font size up there document dot
create
element give see what we get back okay
sometimes chrome tries to be helpful but
it isn't entirely helpful console that
log
there we go okay so if I expand that
then I can see a whole bunch of
properties here it's actually a created
element is actually just a huge
JavaScript object that has a lot of
properties on it and lots of those
things are associated with the Dom
specifically the or our element that
we're creating with react however if I
log that element that we created with
react I'll refresh I'm getting a message
here Thank You Mallory dev tools and
stuff ignore that if I click on this
this console.log thing it's actually
also an object it's not quite as big it
has some like underscore properties
which is basically react telling us hey
don't touch these things this is like
internal implementation stuff so here we
have this type of thing that's just how
react ensures that this is actually a
react element and then we have this key
thing we'll learn more about the key
later when we're entering arrays right
now it doesn't it's not really relevant
and then we have this props thing and
that's those things that we passed here
is the second argument as an object so
that props
object is exactly what we provided and
then we have a ref we'll learn more
about that when we're talking about
interacting with Dom nodes and then a
type that's that first argument so a
react element when you do react create
element you're just creating a
JavaScript object that represents a
react element you can't render react
elements to the Dom with a root element
appendchild you actually need to use
react Dom to do that and react Dom will
will append the child for us and manage
keeping it up-to-date and stuff which
we'll learn more about later so what's
going to do that we're going to do react
which we're getting from this script and
we're gonna render our element do the
root element
and then if we save that refresh well we
get our hello world
so just quick comparison you actually
it's just these lines that are different
yes Thank You AJ for that console tier
that was I should have done that okay so
we have we're creating an ml element
we're setting a couple properties on
that element and then we're appending
that to the document in react you create
an element and you provide some of those
properties and then you use react Dom to
render that to the document okay good so
far hopefully I'm gonna check for a
couple questions
oh I'm blocking the console with my
video thank you for telling me let me
move this around whoo put it over here
or actually you know what maybe instead
I'll just do just screen there you go
you don't need to see my face okay so
let me just check on some of the
questions if there's anything I am gonna
skip some repeat questions and things so
if somebody asks you a question that has
already been asked please do answer them
because I'll be skipping things
okay yep no no question so let's move on
then to our next step so anybody who's
actually used or seen react code before
probably doesn't normally see react
create element in the code and that's
because most of the time we're using
something called JSX because let's say
we wanted to render as like an
additional child another div so I'm
going to create another element here
we'll just bake on styled element
and this one's gonna be a span that says
hello
it doesn't need a class name oh yeah
and then we'll do actually we'll call it
this hello element
we'll have a goodbye element
okay also in
now we want those to be the children
here of this element so we can actually
make children and array because they you
can have multiple children and we'll
have hello element and goodbye element
and we'll save that refresh and now
we're getting hello hello because I
forgot to do world this should not be
goodbye element there should be world
pink bye refresh no notice there's no
space there so let's add a space as a
child
there we go well so this is like totally
not fun to create variables for all this
stuff like clearly this is a hello
element because it has a child flow
element so I don't like I don't want to
name that so let's go ahead and put that
there in its place and we'll do the same
thing for this world element and get rid
of that and now good okay cool we're
we're all set here
except like this is horrid who would
ever want to write code like this not me
and so this is why we have and actually
sorry I have seen some people who don't
like JSX some people will do something
like this they'll say like they'll call
it H I'm not sure why they call it H but
react creates element and then in all
the places where you're using create
element will do H
I honestly don't feel like that's any
better but I have seen people who don't
like to use react create element use H
instead and weird and so yeah what like
let's let's make this a little bit
easier and that's where JSX comes into
play
okay so somebody mentioned I'm going a
little fast so I'm gonna slow down on a
little we're gonna go to exercise number
two it's still in the intro
and here I move to the reacted um
rendered down here and now we're just
getting the element by ID root here so
we don't have to have any extra code
that's arel unwritten irrelevant yeah at
the top
okay so JSX
it's this really a kind of neat thing
let me give you a quick intro so oh
actually I have a newsletter that you
might appreciate just this week's
article is about what we're going to
talk about so if I go what is JSX
and we'll just go through some of these
examples here in just a second but yeah
you can subscribe to this every week I
send out an article and then two weeks
later that hits my blog so let's go
ahead and convert this to JSX wouldn't
it be easier if we could make this be
dev
and close that off and hello world and
then in class name is retainer
I don't looks like HTML right there's
there's a little bit of difference right
here we'll talk about that but yeah it's
a lot easier and now we could actually
add our span low and and base and span
again world right so it definitely looks
a lot better than this but it is the
basically the equivalent of what we had
I mean you just format this a little bit
a prettier formatting isn't applying for
some reason
so this is Janus X we're in JavaScript
we're in text JavaScript right this like
makes total sense inside of HTML but
this isn't JavaScript syntax so this is
what's called JSX
and it is a shorthand for the reax
create element api do for this to work
let's well go ahead and comment this out
if I go to 0 3
oh no we're on to the thing and i
refresh here I'm gonna get a syntax
error unexpected token less than okay so
it's that token right there it's like
wait what is going on here so the
problem here is that because JSX is not
actually javascript you need to convert
it into the JavaScript version of this
same API before the browser runs it and
to do that we use a what's called a
transpiler and a transpiler is able to
make this conversion for us
my transpiler of choice is babel you can
also use typescript typescript will also
transpile JSX code but I have babel
loaded in here as as part of a script
tag so I didn't mention this but I
probably should don't do this in
production bad idea to do in production
but it's great here because it makes it
a lot more clear where the lines are
between abstractions so babel is going
to be responsible for taking all the
code inside of this script tag and doing
its translation magic to convert it to
well
and now this babel script is going to
look in the document for all instances
of script where the type is text Babel
it'll take the contents of that run it
through its magical transpiration to
convert stuff like this into stuff like
this and then and then run that in the
browser so if we save this and refresh
we're going to get our hello world array
and we're also going to get this warning
that says don't do this in production
this is a bad idea
see yeah so I'm not seeing any any other
relevant questions but I am going to
just demo a couple of things for you
that you might want to pull up yourself
so let's go to oh actually sorry one
second I just want to show you there's
no smoke and mirrors going on here so
over here and look at the Dom we're
gonna have that div class this container
here we're calling it class name that's
one of the differences between DOM well
so in my blog post that or my newsletter
that I just sent out this last week
which actually by the way if you
subscribe you'll it'll send it out to
you right now so you can get that in
your inbox but I give a couple examples
I talk about this a little bit more how
react create element just gives you an
object but I'm going to I at the bottom
here I linked to
Babel online Babel has a what's called a
repple that's read evaluate print and I
actually I don't know what it load I
don't know I can't remember what that
last one is so here you can actually
type out your JSX stuff and on the right
side you'll see what babble will turn
that into so one thing I didn't actually
mention to you that I probably should
have is here with this children API you
can actually clean this up a little what
we're looking at a little bit by using a
convenience a part of the API so the
this middle argument to react create
element is the prompts that you pass so
if I said class name I that's going to
be that object right there any other
arguments following that are considered
children so if I do ban or you hello and
and then another span of world
then we're going to see on the right
side we have the type we have the props
and then the rest of the arguments to
this react create element call are the
children
oh that's neat so let's go ahead and
well I'm not gonna waste your time and
[Music]
convert the old one just dress me that's
how it works
um so yeah let's go ahead and we'll just
take this really quick copy this in here
and that's yeah that's what we're gonna
get I think that was basically the same
let's see some other really important
things to know about JSX
is like what if we wanted here we'll say
this is our element
I'm going to do that pretty eye
um what if I wanted to take this
container and extract that class name
out to something else or maybe I want to
make it a dynamic value so here we'll
start with my class name container and
then I can make this dynamic by doing an
interpolation before I show you that
actually I'm going to if you're familiar
with template literals and you can have
something like yeah my HTML equals this
template literal and we're going to have
div
in this template literal and then this
is actual HTML so we'll use class so
this is not JSX it's just that real HTML
so in a template literal you can do
multi lines you can do all kinds of
things but if you want to stick a
variable into that template literal what
you're going to do is use this dollar
sign in these curly braces and
everything that ends up inside of those
curly braces is what's called an
interpolation so you can provide a
JavaScript expression and whatever that
expression evaluates to will get
inserted into that spot in the string so
I'm gonna say my class name and here if
we want to log my HTML let's see if that
happens
yeah tada fancy stuff right so anything
goes in in these interpolations I can do
plus 1 I could even do like regular
arithmetic so now that class is 3 and
then I can do like really weird stuff
too so I could do an immediately invoked
function expression using an arrow
function and this could be like return I
and if we pop open the console here
we're going to get classes high so you
can anything that is a javascript
expression and go inside of these curly
braces okay so that is template literals
Deus Ex is actually really similar in
that if you wanted to make a part of it
dynamic then you turn use and
interpolation and instead of a dollar
and curly braces just use curly braces
and now you're an interpolation zone and
so we can say my class name and it will
be interpolated and the value of my
class name will be assigned to the class
name prop which as you can see on the
right here we have my class name
variable and class name the prop is
getting assigned to my class name so
here we're creating an element it's type
is div and it has these props and before
it
let's look at that again container
the class name is just is the string now
we're doing an interpolation of my class
name
and it's just the the value of the
variable so it's actually not doing a
whole lot of magic things it's just
whatever goes inside of these curly
braces is what's going to be assigned to
the value of that prompt okay so I'm
gonna jump over here really quick to
check out if there are any questions
that are of relevance to everybody
okay yeah so somebody asks a question in
B or stage 2 for Babel or both in
regards to import statements we I can
actually turn that off yeah use E and B
definitely use in B I don't have it
enabled right now I just have react
enabled because I don't want to
transpire all more than me too
oh my dog just walked up I got it cause
this otherwise she'll start howling him
walkout basement so the window is like
at ground level with the dog okay um
let's see yeah any other questions can I
explain things in slightly greater
detail if I'm if you could ask more
specific questions then maybe
am I going to talk about class-based vs.
functional components or function
components yes time is slipping away
very fast but I will I will probably get
to that okay so that's that's Jo sex I
don't think we need to spend any more
time there other than to say you can use
it for attributes you can use it for
values within the like the children area
of the JSX here I added a space and
you'll see actually if I go back and
forth look on the right side here and so
I have an interpolation and then a space
or anything and that will get added as
this additional argument so more
children okay
cool so that III think that's like
really really important to to grab is
interpolations and JavaScript
expressions if you can figure that out
and learn more about what a JavaScript
expression is then you can really nail
JSX and you can come up with new
patterns and and good ways to interact
with your react
okay well let me just check out
something here really quick make sure
I'm not missing anything yeah okay so
wouldn't it be cool if we could have
like let's say we wanted to do at two of
these hello world and goodbye world
and we wanted each one of these to be
inside of a div by themselves
yeah and both of these we want to have a
class name of message actually like it's
your application gets bigger and things
eventually you're going to get to the
point where the you want to make some
sort of abstraction so if we think about
this from a like react create element
standpoint then it might actually make a
little bit more sense so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to comment this out
really quick
and and why is that formatting not
working
yeah I need to set up BS code to format
my HTML I guess I don't know I used to
use atom and it worked great okay so
these things look very similar so in
JavaScript like the way we abstract
things is by making functions so I'm
gonna make a constant message function
and that's just going to be an arrow
function implicit return here and it all
implicitly returned react create element
okay so with that I want to be able to
take what the message should be so I'm
going to call this I'm gonna make it
take an object just for our purposes
here and let's see well stick with the
or actually yeah we'll just do msg or
the message
and then instead of hello world as a
hard-coded string in this function will
just do Emma's well so now I can change
both of these to a function function
call into message okay so if i refresh
laughs is busted what
am I in the right file yet
Oh
Serg message oh right ah you were
supposed to correct me
I was testing you not just kidding I
messed up so we're passing an object
right I'm destructuring that
okay there we go so I'm creating an
object ID structure that object to pull
out the message property and then I pass
that message property along to this
function call of create element as the
child pool okay so how do we do this
same kind of thing in JSX well let's
uncomment this again
and we'll move this up here so we can
use it and we're gonna take this message
and remember any JavaScript expression a
function call is a JavaScript expression
so I can do this and I can do
this okay so as long as I'm in
interpolation mode I I'm in JSX here JSX
JSX boom interpolation now I can do
JavaScript stuff all the way until the
matching curly brace and now boom I'm in
JSX
um here look hello world JSX
Oh busted here we go wait what
my editor is kind of confused there we
go
okay hello world JSX goodbye world right
okay but this is not like this is cool
I've been able to abstract things away
make this thing reusable but it's not a
super great way to compose things
together like let's say for the message
I want it to I don't know here let's
well it'd be more confusing but what if
I wanted to make a message a child of a
message here like I wouldn't really be
able to do that and it doesn't look very
jaya sexy um so let's change this a
little bit remember this react create
element API it takes a string that's a
div it actually also can take something
else what if we could do we're going to
lock this react dot create element
message I want to create an element that
is of type message let's console.log
that and pull up my in here I'm going to
get an object and I get the type is a
function now if you recall I'll do
Dave here
the div is just type is this string and
then here our type is this function and
it's that message function right here
okay so I have created an element that
is of type message can I pass it some
prompts now probably as the second
argument right that's props msg
hello world
well refresh that and now if I look here
prompts okay message helloworld okay
yeah cool so what would happen if I put
that react element in here instead
and I refresh oh look it actually still
works because what I'm rendering now
what I'm interpolating is now not just
well I I'm actually just kind of moving
where things are happening so I'm
creating an element that actually
creates an element itself and I'm and
then I'm rendering that created element
so it would be the same as if I were to
say Const good our other message is a
div I their div and then I can
interpolate that and here so I'm doing
the exact same thing so let's actually
do this
with hello world grant create element
okay so that should work
um but remember how with the react
create element of div I was able to
convert that into this JSX thing which I
kind of really like that I want to be
able to use that and so what if I just
did like message
and then we
this needs to be a prop so msg low world
maybe that works by that refresh oh
that's not gonna work I'm getting a
warning message is unrecognized in this
browser well if we look actually we can
see our message is getting rendered so
the react folks the people who are
making this JSX thing they're like okay
how do we solve this problem we want to
give the same kind of experience with
these custom functions of creating react
elements I want to give that same kind
of experience to that we have for
creating divs and being able to convert
that to JSX
so how do we do that well what if we
tell the remember all of this is getting
converted into these react create
element api's using babel its
transpiling them so what if we just tell
babel that anytime something is
capitalized leave it alone
pilot to this what was before so if we
capitalize this function and then use
that capitalized version but we'll use
the capitalized version in our function
call there and
that
good work
time that's a long enough okay
well okay so we're doing this create
create element of that capital message
rendering that out and in JSX land we
can use the capital version okay well so
let's go ahead and just see this in
action over here if I put message right
there
so it transpires that into react create
element message with our props our props
can be anything they don't have to be
HTML things and in the case of custom
react components like what we've created
here custom functions it's just actually
arguments that our function is getting
passed
and then they can do whatever they want
with those arguments so we're not
forwarding that on as prompts to or
attributes to our div tag
we're forwarding on something else
entirely and we're just using that as
the children the additional arguments
and what's cool about this is now I can
have a much better composability model
so what if we rename this message do
children
now we can take this hello world and
remember this is this is the children
prop right between here that's what
that's what gets accepted as the
children prompts so I take that children
and I remove that and switch it over to
children here asked children as a prop
and now I can say let's switch this over
like quick alright to the pump and yeah
we'll just do
okay
Oh
but I have this really nice looking it's
almost like HTML but it's not quite HTML
and what's cool about this is now I can
put things or I can nest things just
like I would a normal HTML so now I've
got a message in a message we can see
that evidenced here we have this message
in a message and I have this really
really nice composability model where I
can create custom components custom
functions that return more JSX
and react can create elements out of
those and it will continue down the
chain until it finds all of the elements
that are type or type span or actual Dom
elements use lower case elements let's
actually rewrite this really quick to
just be JSX the more typical standard
here so we're gonna do a div and class
name is going to equal message and then
build Rijn is children
prop right self closing tag that's one
handy thing with JSX
is you don't need to actually close dude
so if you don't have any children that
you're putting in between an opening and
closing in yourself close it
okay so that's working but again I don't
like the children prop when I'm using
JSX
so I'll just do
do this
now I do have a self closing time or non
self closing I have a closing tag well
and that works and so now things look a
fair amount more palatable and it's
easier to reuse this stuff let me just
put this on whoops new line there
um and I can create all the custom
components that you could imagine so to
create a custom component in react you
make a function
and it's called whatever you want so my
component that was really boring and
then it accepts props
and those props are whatever our past my
component
as prop 1
hi and prompt to is through top three is
34 and whatever else prompt or is
function to be anything
and then in here we can use those props
and return more JSX earn if I we don't
have to use the props just get them and
we render more JSX that more JSX can
actually be
um yet another component and its
components all the way down
well so it's been a little bit I'm gonna
check on the questions we've only got
like 10 minutes left which is
unfortunate but this is like paramount
ly important for you to be successful
using react or most efficient using
reactant so that's why I include it
okay let's see couple of questions
so am i explaining what's happening
under the hood or is this really react
so yeah so like this isn't typical react
like in an application you will not see
react to it in this way we're starting
to get to more typical reacts with the
JSX stuff but yeah mostly I'm just
trying to explain how this JSX stuff
works and JavaScript expressions because
it's really really important to being
successful in understanding what's going
on with the future stuff
okay cool so I'm just gonna show you a
couple of things because we were limited
on time and then I'm I'll go through a
couple exercises probably so when you
want to like spend more time in these
exercises just a couple of things I have
a another process over here that's
running NPM start so you're on NPM start
enter in your terminal and it'll pop
open an app that looks like this and in
here you'll have the exercise version
and the final version and for each one
of these exercises that we have and upon
step
so the yeah so that's that's the actual
app you can also do this in in code
sandbox the app works there too we also
have some tests oh whoops that so if you
run NPM T to run the test or NPM run
tests or NPM test all three of those
things will work then it'll start just
in watch mode and just watch mode is
awesome if you hit the P key you can
filter by filename regex pattern so
we'll do is 0 1 or actually here let's
see which one do we want to do we're
gonna
[Music]
got that label drawing
we'll probably do this one actually you
know
with the last 10 minutes I'll do I'll do
this one and you'll see a bunch of stuff
that you hadn't seen but hopefully it'll
give your mind the idea of what you want
to or what's possible so yeah we're
going to be doing number 5 and so that
will just filter down to the tests that
are in that match that pattern which is
just the 0-5 exercise and then if we go
to our test directory 0-5 we can comment
out exercise final come into an exercise
0 5 and it will start failing and I'll
tell you what's going on and you're
supposed to supposed to do some stuff to
make things things work so let's go
ahead and jump into number 5 on the
exercises thing and I'll work through
this and that that'll be the end of our
doodad for today oh hey let me jump over
to 5 or actually the URL just 0 5
so this is the final version of what
we're going to build jumping around a
bit
yikes there we go well so then we stop
start stop clear start clear that's what
it's what we're going to build here with
react
um I mean you actually just jump over
here really quick make sure I don't mess
up really bad
okay well so to get us started I'm
actually going to just go the isolated
example of exercise so that we can be
focused okay so the first thing that I
get that I like to do when I'm creating
a component oh sorry
take a step back because we kind of
skipped over a couple things so you know
how I made a function message that takes
some props and then you can return some
JSX from that so you can actually use a
class as well javascript class and the
only stipulation is that the class has
to extend react component and with that
and like some of this stuff will be new
to you and I don't have time to explain
it all because we just have like five
minutes left
but yeah so here we're creating a
property that will be attitude every
instance of the stopwatch class that we
instantiate and that property is called
state and this is the initial value when
that is constructed and so yeah we're
going to start with a elapse of zero and
it's not running so that's our initial
initial state there and then we're gonna
do a bunch of things here that's Cody
the koala bear helping us out and then
we're going to we every react class has
a render method so if you're if you're
using a function that function is the
render method so that message function
its render method is something that
returns more JSX
more react elements so here we're
creating a class that has a render
method and that render method is
responsible for returning the JSX
so that's what we're going to do here
I'm going to create a div we'll get rid
of this thing and it will return that
div let's render our label so our label
is going to say the elapsed time and
here inside of this render we have
access to this dot state and this dot
state has a property on it called laps
so that's what we want to render
say
actually this is interpolation right
here laps
we're interpolating the laps variable
into there and then m/s for milliseconds
and we save that and we're going to see
zero milliseconds awesome we're gonna
have two buttons one that says clear and
then this one that says running or it
says stop if it's running and start if
it's not running so let's pull out the
running State
and here we'll say if it's running
you're gonna see a lot of turn Aires in
JSX because the ternary is an expression
you can't do like an if statement inside
of the JSX if you want to do that you
can do that up here but I like that and
then you can make like a let element
equal or whatever and then if and then
set the element and then render the
element but I like to just inline it so
we'll use a ternary so if we're running
then we're going to say stop otherwise
we'll say start
and save that and now
do we have a start and a clear let's go
ahead and add a couple of styles so I
skipped over this but in and react and
with JSX you can use the style prop but
the way that it or the style attribute
so I can regular HTML you have a style
attribute you can have a string of CSS
but that string of CSS doesn't compose
very well so you can't like you can
concatenate strings of CSS but I how do
you reliably override things and and
stuff like that it's just like a little
bit harder and so and but here we have
button styles and label Styles so let's
apply those so a style equals that
object and like really often you'll see
that in line two like border border and
stuff like that but we have this as a
variable and so we'll just interpolate
that variable
and what happened button styles for both
of those and then style is label I'll I
was with an S and mm refresh but uh it
looks all night yes s is pretty cool
okay so let's go ahead and make this
interactive so we skipped over the event
handling stuff but we want to add a
quick Handler on to this button
unfortunately in like regular JavaScript
and like with jQuery and stuff ya have
to say okay find me that button node and
I'm add eventlistener on to it and now I
have a JavaScript callback that responds
whenever that listener happens in react
it's a lot more direct a lot more
straightforward what's going on we
simply have on click and this on quick
we're going to assign it to do a
instance variable we're going to call
and all run click
and we'll just make that one work for
now actually you know what let's let's
do the easier one first so I have on
click and this will be this dot handle
quick quick
and you know what all these comments are
just expecting me oh I'm getting get rid
of all that stuff okay it's not all that
bad
so we need this handle quick quick to be
an instance method
and it's just going to be a narrow
function so it can make use of the
lexical this and I actually just today
talked about this in tips so I have
daily videos that I put out during the
weekday that are just little tips and
stuff today was how does this work in
JavaScript so you can learn more about
the reason that I'm doing this arrow
function thing so go check that out
yeah how does this work in JavaScript
um yeah don't Google that case you need
cuz you'll find a million things YouTube
and then you can find mine out there
okay so hey no quick quick here we need
to update the running state so that it's
no longer running I'm going to
initialize it to true so we can see this
handle quick quick actually working and
we'll start out here with alert I just
to make sure that things are wired up
properly but when I click on a handle
quick quick it's gonna or sorry when I
click on the Clear button it's gonna
call my handle quick quick call back and
that should Alert so like quick but uh
hi we and we know we're in a running
state because stop is showing it and so
now we need to change that state we need
to tell react hey listen I know that the
state is running true but I'd like to
change it to running false if that's
cool with you and so we'll say this dot
set state now where is this set State
method coming from I don't see it in
here coming from react component we're
extending react component grant
component provides this dot set state
and here we can say running is false and
it's not going to change the value of
our laps it does a shallow merge of our
properties so we don't have to say like
emerge this dot state or whoops we'd do
that on the other side did because react
will actually do that for us and so we
just provide the state the first level
of the object the properties that we
want changed so cool let's we'll save
that this it's refreshed and I click on
clear and you'll see the stuff to start
well so the Clear button is working
let's make the on click
this dot handle or run quick
that one's tricky because it's also its
start and it's stop but that's what
we're gonna call it we're gonna do the
same thing here there's going to be an
arrow function and I need to determine I
need to set some state I need to make
some changes to state I need to say that
it's it's running now or it's not
running now and I need to know what the
current value of state is and so I can't
say this dot state dot running and I can
know okay if it's running then I want to
change it to writing false otherwise
running true or whatever and then like I
need to start a timer somewhere but for
reasons that I don't have time to get
into if react actually well I have some
time to get into it watch this okay so
if I wanted to instead of this dot false
I wanted to call set state a bunch of
times and maybe it wouldn't all be right
here in the same function and it'd be
part of the code path like this calls
another function which calls set state
and that caused another one and whatever
and let's say that I was using not this
state dot running
okay so I'm saying okay set state
running is the opposite of what the
current state is then I'm going to
toggle it back and toggle it back and
talk about back so we're bumping back
and forth between running and not
running if I save that
then presumably we're we're in a running
true state so this should now say
running false running true any false
running true okay by quick on where
actually I need to be an odd number this
show the problem sorry I quick
did I mess something up
yeah yeah so it's going to talk about
every single time so what's happening
here is the set state
method is actually batched and so it
doesn't run synchronously so here may be
a better way to illustrate this is this
dot state dot running and i'll
console.log that between every single
one of these
and we'll do another one at the
beginning
pop open the dev tools
and if I click on clear I'm gonna get
true every single time even though I'm
calling set state each one of these
times I'm getting through every time and
so set state is its run in a batch and
the reason for that is it like we don't
want to render like a million times to
our user like it's kind of nonsensical
to do this like I could just store up a
variable and then set state once but
react doesn't want to make you have to
think about that or worry about that
worried about performance this is one
thing that react as for performance so
it waits until all of your set state
calls have run and then it flushes the
state to determine what the actual state
should be so anyway that whole long
thing that I just went through all just
to say that here when we do a handle run
quick if I want to get this dot state
about running then and I'm going to be
updating state we're going to do rain
I need to say hey react what is the
state of running at this time in our
batch run so I'm going to say this dot
set state and we're going to use a
function and so then if I call this over
and over and over again it's going to
react can run this one and then this one
and each time it's going to give me the
state
and it'll give me an opportunity to
return what I want for this and the new
state to be based off of the current
state in our current batch run
okay so that may be a little bit heavy
and I'm sorry about that that I didn't
have quite as much time to to get deeper
into that but just if you don't like
complicated rules of like that I use an
object or should I use a function then
just always use a function and you don't
have to accept any arguments so we could
actually refactor this and this is
probably what I should have done and not
gotten into all this stuff but
so that is totally cool and to do things
out this way if you if you want to just
always use a function I have no qualms
with that
okay cool so here we're going to get our
state and we can say if state running
then we're going to do something
otherwise we're going to do something
else
and in either case we're gonna return
date dot or actually we're gonna we're
gonna toggle the running state right so
I'm going to say running is an opposite
of state running
okay well so we're not actually doing
actually running any of these like a
timer yet or anything updating that
lapse value but we can stop and start
and clear and stop it started stop all
right and clear though all of that is
working our running state is being
updated properly so we're we're gold in
there so what we need to do now is if
state running then we need to set an
interval
and let's see so every like as soon as
possible
that's the default zero so as soon as
possible I want to update the laps I
need to know what the current the start
time is so we'll say start time equals
date now
and now I can get what the Lapps is with
let's see or well we'll just say this
dot set state laps we don't need to know
what the previous laps was so we can
just use an object here and I'll say
start time or sorry date dot now - the
start time
okay well let's see what happens and I
do that
I actually put that in the wrong spot
that should be there but anyway that's
working cool isn't that okay so listen
every single time that number is
changing that's that's happening as fast
as possible as fast as a set interval is
running and it's running all this stuff
doing react create element or the div
and the label in the button it's running
all of that over and over and over again
as fast as a browser could possibly go
it's gonna nuts I think that's pretty
cool I love doing this exercise because
I like to see that but now we have no
way to stop this so I hit clear and
running is now false but this keeps on
going and that's happening because
inside the set interval we're calling
this dots that stay on laps over and
over and over again we need to clear
this interval what I'm going to do is
I'm going to set a property this dot
interval
and inside of this handle quick quick
I'm going to say clear interval this
interval
and so with that I can now refresh
dart and then clear and it stops it
doesn't change the the laps though so
let's have that set state change to the
laps to zero
sighs this to false now because that
makes more sense
and so I start it and then I clear it
start it and then I stop it well sobbing
doesn't work yet so let's make stop work
so here if it is running then we're
going to stop it so I'll say clear
interval we're interval this dot
interval
hey and then
yeah that's actually it for that so I
can now start and I don't want to set it
to 0 milliseconds anymore but when I hit
start again it's going to start over I
don't want it to start over so what
we're going to do is I'm going to move
this start time to up here
oh actually no that doesn't work hold on
how did I solve that
sorry I'm cheating
oh right you know what
all that stuff that I said rats
oh I know what I'm doing okay sorry let
me just copy this over because I don't
want to waste your time and I'll explain
things
yeah
okay so magic happens so here we're
saying if the state is running then
we're gonna just clear the interval
otherwise we're going to do this set
interval and then here where we're
calling set state to swap the running
state we're using the state updater
function to be perfectly honest like in
this situation using state update or
functions versus using just regular
objects it's really not that huge of a
deal so I would like encourage you not
to get dogmatic about this but it is
just a good general practice to avoid
surprising bugs by using a state updater
if you need to reference the state
that's all I'm going to say about that
so here though we are determining what
to do based off of the state whether to
even set the state or start this
interval and so in this situation it is
totally like it's actually better to use
this density term right
okay cool and so then when we set our
interval we get our start time and yeah
so let's did I save that no I don't
think I did well save that and start and
stop and start again and stop again yeah
this is actually the magic that was I
could have fixed this the start time is
now a variable based off of the current
elapsed time that's what fixed the bag
okay cool so that's actually almost it
there's one last thing and I can't
really demonstrate it with the way that
this works right now but I'll just
explain it so let's say that let's see
yeah let's say that I have a toggle
button or something to render the
stopwatch and so if I toggle it on it
renders a stopwatch I toggle it off dump
watch it's gone it's completely removed
from the Dom like I would have some
state that says this dot state dot
render stopwatch then I ran a stopwatch
otherwise I don't render anything just
know
and so when react reruns the render
method it's going to actually remove not
only the Dom notes but it all destroyed
the component as well so it gets garbage
collected and whatever it's just an old
object so in that kind of situation if
the stopwatch we're running at the time
that it gets ripped out then this set
interval is still going to be happening
we're calling this dot set state every
like millisecond or as quickly as we
possibly can and so that can be a
problem because it means that every
instance of the stopwatch that gets
rendered will hang around forever
because it can't get garbage collected
because it's being referenced inside of
this callback function so we need to
clear this away clear this interval
right before react removes things from
the Dom and tries to destroy the
instrument instance what react calls
that is mounting so when a component I'm
going to stop this it's probably
distracting
when a component is rendered to the page
it's going to be mounted to the page so
there's a life cycle hook called the
component did mount there's an inverse
life cycle method for when react is
going to pull it off the page and throw
it away
that's called component did unmount it
and that's what we need we need to say
hey react before you take this off I
want to do some work and so we're gonna
say component did unmount and that
accepts the that's component did update
whoops oh it did unmount I guess I don't
have an autocomplete that that's to add
okay component oh sorry that's component
we'll unmount sorry it's me yeah and
that doesn't accept any arguments that's
what threw me off okay so component will
unmount it's like hey react is like hey
by the way this thing's about to go away
do any of your cleanup work and all we
really need to do is this clear interval
and that will prevent a memory leak
really important for stuff where you set
up callbacks like if you're subscribing
to a store or you're subscribing to some
third party service like a socket or
something like that then you're going to
want to use component to done mount to
clean up those subscriptions
okay so there's a ton more stuff in here
like we had this really cool thing to
interact with the whoops go interact
with the Dom and a fun vanilla tilt
library also using forms submit that's
yeah and then like low lose so like a
validation also check this out Apple and
all those things are synced together and
stuff so all of these things I show you
how to do I I show you some of the
pitfalls with the rendering arrays and
then making HTTP requests so I don't
have time to show you all that stuff
right now cuz I'm gonna go hang out with
my wife but if you want to see some of
this stuff then you can go to kcd - IM
beginner react and this is a totally
free course available on egghead io
about the beginner's guide to react and
it has like all this same content I
don't go quite as deep into stuff and
it's a little bit faster pace you can
slow down the video if you want I guess
but yeah it's actually just about an
hour and yeah hopefully that kind of
fills in some of the gaps if some of
this was a little more confusing here at
the end but yeah I think that's pretty
much it if you I want to get to my sites
there are those and definitely feel free
to ping me on Twitter and also my AMA if
you have any questions I've got lots and
lots of stuff on on my email like 400
questions already so you can peruse
those too I'm gonna check really quick
if anybody has last-minute questions and
then we'll wrap this up so um let's see
doesn't look like it's a complete list
on the github I'm not sure what your
suggested are saying there that but I
yeah I should mention that the number 11
here yeah this is a to do but all the
other ones are done and this should be
done here before too long I'm going to
be doing this eventually
[Music]
do you need aeronite
for the oh oh I'm so glad you asked this
I press and yeah okay so really quick
and if you look at my dev tips how does
this work in JavaScript you'll
understand why I'm using this syntax
normally you'll want to use this in text
so this is a member property every
single instance of the component this as
this stopwatch component is going to get
a its own copy of the handle quick click
function component will unmount render
lifecycle hooks like this these will be
a single function that's assigned to the
prototype of stopwatch and so all the
instances of stopwatch will have access
to it through its prototype so yeah the
pretty much the kind of the rule is if
you're passing a function do as a prop
where you don't control where it's
called then you're probably going to
want to use this syntax to make it at
work so that you can use this inside
yeah that also only applies if you're
actually using this if you're not using
this dot then you don't need to worry
about it either
so yeah definitely watch this that'll
probably give you a better idea of why
but yeah if you can try to use the
method because it's less memory
intensive but if you can't then this is
acceptable also
I think that's it so I'm gonna jump off
I'm um
yeah I hope that you're all like
found this hopefully sort of useful and
I will see you all later here I'm just
gonna do a goodbye see ya
I don't have a I have a be right back
I've just the screen just me me on the
screen starting and then I've got my
sweet dev tips intro so I'll just play
that for you until they they turn me off
bye